hello everyone
welcome to this interesting video on
cryptocurrency full course
in this video we will explore all the
important features and concepts
revolving around cryptocurrencies
and will also come across some of the
very interesting facts
and figures about them starting with
understanding
what cryptocurrency is then we will
explore some very important and popular
cryptocurrencies according to market cap
starting with discussing facts and
components
about bitcoin followed by how to mine
bitcoin
after which we will understand what
ethereum is
and will explore its upgrade as well as
how we can mine ethereum
after that we will have a comparison
between bitcoin and ethereum then we
will explore
our third crypto dogecoin and its
various components like dogecoin mining
dojo and wallet
and its comparison with other
cryptocurrencies then
we will jump into the other side and
explore some of the other popular
aspects of cryptocurrencies
like nft salana and shebainu coin
we will then conclude this video by
discussing the recent downfall of crypto
market
by the end of this video i can assure
you that you will have thor knowledge
as well as a clear picture of
cryptocurrencies and crypto market
for this training with me i have i
experienced blockchain specialist
rahul together we will take you through
the various important keynotes
of cryptocurrency so let's start with an
exciting video on cryptocurrency full
course
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
and never miss an update from simply
learn meet frank and daniel
one day they decided to go for a trip to
venice
they made a budget list for all their
expenses like residence
flight etc they thought of making their
bookings online from a site that offered
discounts to the first 10 visitors on
that day
while making their respective flight
bookings daniel's transaction failed
and he missed the offer going on on the
other hand
frank paid his share very quickly and
easily
and became one of the three lucky draw
winners daniel was surprised
and asked frank how he could make the
transaction when daniel himself could
not
to which his response was it's simple i
used bitcoin a type of cryptocurrency
daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is
and since when has it been in use frank
stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency
that works on blockchain technology and
is designed to work as a medium of
exchange online to buy goods and
services
and make payments which was introduced
to the world first in 2013
by satoshi nakamoto daniel felt that it
sounds similar to other online payment
options
he asked what makes it so different
frank explained
cryptocurrency is decentralized and free
from any third-party interference
which means it is not issued and
controlled by any government or central
authority
unlike other payment systems that banks
or governments are handling
and that's why a cryptocurrency
transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
daniel's transaction failed
like he may have exceeded his transfer
limit for his account
must have been hacked or there could
have been some technical issue with his
bank server
or maybe due to high transaction fees
imposed by the bank
but on the other hand cryptocurrency
charges almost
no or very low transaction cost there is
no limit for making transactions
in fact you have 24 7 access to your
money there is no extra delay or extra
charges on making international
transactions
and the best part is that anybody can
use cryptocurrency
without the hassles of paperwork all you
need to do is create an account
on any digital wallet of cryptocurrency
this is what makes cryptocurrency
different from other online payment
options
daniel was impressed by cryptocurrency
but he wondered how it works without the
control of an external authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works
on blockchain technology blockchain is a
set of blocks that record information of
transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital ledger that is distributed
across the entire network
meaning the data is replicated and
stored on each node across the entire
blockchain network
making it more secure and impossible to
change
hack or cheat the system then it is
verified and validated by
every node to proceed with the process
of making the transactions
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography
which is a method of using encryption
and decryption to secure the data
in the presence of any third party with
ulterior motives
now daniel was completely aware of the
whole technology and concept
behind cryptocurrency and was influenced
by frank to adopt cryptocurrency
in his daily lifestyle too he did that
by booking his ticket
but sadly no discount like daniel
cryptocurrency has influenced and
impacted
an enormous number of people worldwide
due to this increasing popularity
new companies like metoo and paypal are
coming forward and investing in
cryptocurrency
every day in 2018 malta an island
located in the mediterranean sea
south of italy was titled blockchain
island as it led to the economic
stability of the nation
many fintech companies like binance and
okcx
have already begun to take advantage of
malta's financial incentives
and have moved their headquarters to the
blockchain island so
here is a question for you which hashing
algorithm does cryptocurrency use
a script b ethash
c sha 256 d
none of the above please give it a
thought and drop your answers in the
comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
cryptocurrency is revolutionizing
finance and banking around the world
thanks to cryptocurrency now anyone with
an internet connection can trade
spend and borrow money around the world
and nobody can stop them
people like bill gates co-founder of
microsoft corporation
and elon musk ceo of tesla support
cryptocurrency
as it is much better and secure than
physical money and also holds a great
future for the world's economy
and on the other hand some people think
of cryptocurrency as
a bane to the world's economy like
warren buffett ceo of berkshire hathaway
and ajay benga ceo of global mastercard
feel that cryptocurrency is a platform
of criminal activities
and will destroy the world's economy
well one thing is clear
that this conflict is going to stay put
for a little longer hi guys today
we're going to talk about 10 things you
didn't know about bitcoin
firstly we have the mysterious creator
now in 2009
a person or a group of people known as
satoshi nakamoto introduced bitcoin to
the world he vanished off the internet
in late 2010
he hasn't been heard from since now just
like his identity is shorter than
mystery
nobody really knows if he's even alive
or dead the only communication
people had with him were through emails
and forums his bitcoin wallet holds
around 980
000 bitcoins which makes him one of the
richest people on the planet
next up we have the satoshi now as a
sign of respect for the bitcoin's
creator the smallest unit of a bitcoin
is known as a satoshi one satoshi is
valued at around 0.000
669 for us dollars which is a very very
low value
now to make one bitcoin you need
approximately 100 million satoshi's now
according to the current bitcoin values
which fluctuates a lot
to make a dollar you'd need close to 15
800 satoshi's
losing bitcoins losing your bitcoin
address which is also known as your
private key
not only means losing your unique
identification it also means you lose
all the bitcoins in your wallet research
shows that at least 60 percent of
all bitcoin addresses are ghosts which
means a huge chunk of the population
that's using the bitcoin network have
lost their addresses now these are the
people who have lost their addresses
and have no way to access their wallet
liberland
now in april 2015 a micro nation between
croatia and serbia
known as liberland was born now this was
founded by virgil
a politician publicist activist and the
president of liberland
now the official currency of liberland
is bitcoin now the government took this
move
believing that bitcoin and its
underlying concepts of blockchain
provides a secure and transparent method
for recording electronic financial
and physical assets processing power the
process of mining bitcoins is a
expensive process now you pay a high
toll to do this like your money
your time and electricity now mining
bitcoins require servers that are used
for that specific purpose alone now the
faster you process the data the faster
the block can be added to the blockchain
and the faster you're rewarded with
bitcoins power consumption
now just imagine how much electricity
ireland consumes in a year
approximately 5000 kilowatt hour now how
much do you think
all the bitcoin mining farms together
consume sixty terawatt ah
which is approximately six into ten
raised to ten kilowatt hours which is a
large amount of power
now the entire country of ireland which
is the second most populated city in
europe
and has 84 421 kilometers square of area
consumes lesser electricity than all
these farms combined
bitcoin ban now although several
countries around the world
like canada and america have
wholeheartedly accepted bitcoin
there are some that haven't countries
like bolivia iceland bangladesh and
ecuador
have completely banned the usage of
bitcoins there are also countries like
india thailand and iran who ask their
residents to be careful while using
cryptocurrencies they haven't completely
banned it however
they do not accept it as a legal tender
law limited number
there's a limit to how many bitcoins can
exist in the market
this number is capped at 21 million
bitcoins
as of this moment 17 million bitcoins
are already in circulation
to give you an idea that's almost 80
percent of the 21 million
already done but don't worry until 2140
we'll still have bitcoins to mine
this is because of how miners are
rewarded now miners are rewarded with
12.5 bitcoins for each block
added to the blockchain and every four
years the reward reduces by half
the next halving is supposed to occur in
2020 where the reward reduces to 6.25
bitcoins
the power of b the terms bitcoin with an
uppercase b
and bitcoin with the lowercase b mean
two different things
the only thing that differentiates the
two into two completely different things
is the letter b
the lowercase b in bitcoin refers to the
cryptocurrency that is used to perform
the transactions
the uppercase b in bitcoin refers to the
ledger that stores information
regarding these transactions faster than
supercomputers the world's fastest
supercomputer the summit works at 122.3
petaflops which is nothing but
a quadrillion floating point operations
per second now if you take the bitcoin
network completely into consideration
the processing power is about 80 million
704
290 petaflops but the only thing here is
that a supercomputer can do several
different things but the only thing the
bitcoin network does
is add blocks to the blockchain let's
talk about what is bitcoin mining so
what is bitcoin so let's check an
example
so there is someone who wants to send
five bitcoins
to rachel now we will see how this
transaction can happen
now bitcoin is based on the concept
of digital currency anyone across the
globe
can transfer amount in bitcoin
irrespective of the geography
from anyone to anyone so basically you
need to just
open an account on the bitcoin network
have some bitcoins in it and you can
transfer it either you can purchase the
bitcoins
online through some exchanges or you can
mine it so once you have bitcoins in
your account
you can transfer it to someone you want
whose address you have now do you want
to know how this transaction work
well this transaction is done by bitcoin
mining
so we will go deep and understand that
how
the bitcoin transaction works what all
entities are involved behind the scenes
in order to maintain the sanity of the
bitcoin network
and make sure that whomever you wanted
the bitcoin to reach to
has reached and there is no loss of
bitcoin in the network and it is a
successful transaction so let's
understand certain basics
so what's in it for us today we need to
know what is bitcoin
we will understand the underlying
technology blockchain so we will talk
about that then we will see what are the
advantages of bitcoin
as compared to other digital currencies
and other digital technologies then we
will go into the concepts of bitcoin
mining
then what is bitcoin mining and we will
do a demo on
certain aspects of bitcoin mining now
what is bitcoin bitcoin is the first
decentralized digital currency that
allows users to transfer money peer to
peer
without any intermediaries like banks
governments agents brokers nothing is
involved
and all this is done using blockchain
technology so as we saw in our previous
example
two parties wants to exchange money
transfer money they don't need an
intermediary now bitcoin
can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions
it can be used as an investment
instrument and it can be primarily used
for payments
to buy goods and services now it was
created
in 2009 it came into existence by
a person or a group of people called
satoshi nakamoto
now bitcoin helps transferring of assets
faster
than regular fiat currencies it has
definitely lower transaction fees
because
as it has removed the intermediaries
from between the cost of transaction
also goes down and it is
cryptographically secure
it uses cryptography infrastructure and
thereby the identities
of the sender and the receiver are also
secure and
entire transaction is cryptographically
signed and the users
information who are doing the
transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden and secure
now what are the advantages of bitcoin
so
it allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions
it is impossible to counterfeit or hack
the transactions which are running on a
bitcoin network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions
or charging a fees in order to validate
the transaction
it is the participants in the
decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low
all the information is accessible to
public it is available publicly on a
public ledger anyone can go and view the
transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the bitcoin network and
it is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other
mediums and channels through which today
digital transactions are made now what
is blockchain so bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger
in which transactions made in bitcoins
or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features
it is cryptographically secure signed
using your private key and then
shared on the network with the public
key it is immutable
any record or any transaction added on
the blockchain cannot be modified or
altered
it is run by a decentralized system
there is no centralized authority of the
body
and the transactions are stored in
containers
aggregated in containers called blocks
so
a block is the smallest unit of a
blockchain
which records all the transaction a
basic structure of a block
is something like this it has four
fields these are the primary attributes
for block
it has something called as previous hash
so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block
and that's how the blocks are linked to
each other
data this is the aggregated set of
transactions
which are included in this block so
these are the set of transactions
which were mined and validated and
included in the block
nonce so in proof of work consensus
algorithm
which is used in bitcoin nonce is a
random value
which is used to vary the output of the
hash value so every block
is supposed to generate a hash value and
nonce is the parameter which is used to
generate that hash value
and the proof of work is the process of
transaction verification
done in blockchain now hash is the
resultant hash value
obtained by passing the previous hash
value
the data and the nonce through the
sha-256 algorithm to generate the hash
of this block
so this is the digital signature of the
block which is generated
and this is the basically identity of
this block
now sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces
a unique 256-bit alphanumeric hash value
for any given input and that is the
unique feature of this cryptographic
algorithm whatever
input you give it will always produce a
256-bit hash
now let's understand the concepts of
bitcoin miami what is bitcoin mining
bitcoin mining is the process of
verifying
bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the
public blockchain ledger in blockchain
the transactions
are verified by bitcoin users
so basically the transactions have to be
verified by none other than the
participants of the network
those who have the required hardware and
computing power
and those entities are called miners so
we will be talking about them later
but the point to be highlighted is that
there is nothing like a centralized body
as in case of legacy transactions where
we used to be dependent on
a regulatory or governing body or a bank
to make our transactions go through now
in bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart
that kind of computer can be a
participant and contribute to the
mining community process is solved based
on a difficult mathematical puzzle
called proof of work so every miner's
job is to solve the mathematical puzzle
which is called proof of work in order
to validate the transaction
and earn the reward and all the miners
as they are competing amongst themselves
to mine
a particular transaction the miner who
first solves the person
gets the reward now users trying to sell
the puzzle as i said are called miners
they are the participants in the network
who have the necessary hardware
and computing power to do all the
transactions to validate the
transactions and validated they are
called as
miners now in order to understand
bitcoin mining we need to understand
three major concepts of blockchain it is
based on distributed public ledger
it uses sha-256 encryption algorithm
and proof of work is the underlying
consensus
algorithm for bitcoin mining so
distributed public ledger
a distributed ledger is a record of all
transactions
maintained in the blockchain network
across the globe
in the network the validations of
transaction
is done by bitcoin users called as
miners sha-256 now blockchain prevents
unauthorized access by using a hash
function
called sha-256 to ensure that the blocks
are kept secure they are digitally
signed their hash value once generated
cannot be altered
now seq 256 it takes an input string
of any size and returns a fixed length
256 bit
output value and that is the primary
feature of
shf 256 encryption algorithm you give
any input it will always give you a
256 bit output and it is a one-way
function you cannot derive the input
reversally from the output what you have
generated
and third is the proof of work in
blockchain
mining is a process to validate
transactions
by solving a difficult mathematical
puzzle called proof of work now in order
to do that
the primary objective of the minor is to
determine the nonce value
and that nonce value is that
mathematical puzzle that miners required
to solve
in order to generate a hash which is
less than the target
defined by the network for a particular
block now in the bitcoin network
users trying to solve mathematical
puzzles are called as
minus now the puzzle is solved by
varying
a nonce which produces a hash value
lower than a predefined condition which
is called as the target
miners verify the transactions and add
the block
to the blockchain when confirmed and
verified
as of today the miners who solve the
puzzle
gets a reward of 12.5 bitcoins
now once a block is added to the
blockchain the bitcoins
associate with the transactions can be
spent so once
the block is validated then the transfer
of bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block
the transfers are made then from one
account to the another now
in order to generate the hash let's see
you use the sha-256 hashing algorithm
you define the hash value
if it is less than the defined condition
the target then the puzzle
is deemed to be solved and if not then
you keep on incrementing nonce value and
you repeat the sha-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
define
generate the hash value again and you
keep doing this process till the time
you get the
hash value which is less than the target
now let's check an example
so for example beyonce wants to share 10
bitcoin with jennifer
now in order to do that what will be the
steps so beyond
transaction data is shared with bitcoin
users the miners from the
memory code the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of
unmined transactions so in a memory pool
set of
unmined or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a
new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool
now miners competing to validate the
transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the
unconfirmed transaction pool they pick
up those transactions
and start validating those transactions
they aggregate
in a data block and start validating
they start solving the puzzle
the miner who solves the puzzle first
shares his result
across the other nodes the other set of
miners
now once the block has been verified the
nonce has been
generated then the nodes will start
granting their approval if maximum nodes
grant their approval the block becomes
valid and is added to the
blockchain now simultaneously the miner
who has solved the puzzle will also
receive the reward in the meanwhile
which will be of 12.5 bitcoin which as
of today stands at
98k around dollars now the bitcoins the
10 btc for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred
from beyond to jennifer now let's take a
look at certain
facts in proof of work a predefined
condition the target
is adjusted for every 2016 block
which is approximately every 14 days and
an average
time to mine a block is 10 minutes so
basically the target
keeps automatically adjusting itself to
keep the block generation
within the 10 minute time frame so this
is the representation
so in order to keep the time frame for
block generation within 10 minutes the
target keeps on
adjusting itself now the difficulty of
the puzzle changes the target changes
depending on the time it takes to mine a
block so this is how
a difficulty of a block is being
generated
it is the hash target of the first block
divided by the hash target of the
current block so this is the difficulty
which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically
it is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify
by the miners so once you have solved
the puzzle
and you have broadcasted that yes you
have earned you have validated a record
you have
determined the puzzle for other miners
it is very easy to verify what you have
done and once they give their consensus
the majority
then the block gets validated and gets
added to the
blockchain now since the difficulty
depends on the hash target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block
as i said and as you can see in due
course
from the day of inception of bitcoin in
2009 till today
difficulty has increased exponentially
and it has been increasing and thereby
the entire
effort of mining and the computing power
is also increasing
so as of what was the resources which
were required to
do mining in 2009 you require more
hashing power
more computing power in order to do the
mining today now
what if someone tries to hack the data
so
let's see blockchain is a chain of
blocks abc
now each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now
suppose a person tries to tamper a block
block b
and tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if
the data of the block will change the
hash value which is the digital
signature of the block
will also change thereby it will corrupt
the chain which is subsequent to it
basically
the blocks ahead of block b will all get
the link because the previous hash value
of block c will not remain valid so
in order for the hacker to make the
entire blockchain valid for the block b
which he has changed he has to change
the hash value of
all the blocks ahead of block b which
will require
huge huge amount of computing power
which will be next to impossible so as
you see the results in the following
block
being invalid so with this whole thing
the blockchain
is making sure that the entire sequence
remains
non-hackable and prevent data
modification now
let's see what are the underlying
hardware requirements for bitcoin mining
and how the hardware is evolved so in
the early days miners used to solve the
puzzles using regular processors
the controlling processor unit cpus now
but it used to take a lot of time
for mining though the difficulty levels
were low but still it used to take a lot
of time
now as i said the difficulties never
keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so this
discovered
that graphical processing units gpus
proved
to be more efficient than regular cpus
so but this also had a drawback of
consumption of electricity so any miner
who has to
calculate the return on investment on
the hardware he also has to
accommodate the cost of electricity and
other resources which are going in
in order to do the mining so finally as
of today
they are using a hardware called asic
application specific integrated circuit
which was specifically introduced for
mining which consumes
less power and has a higher computing
power and a better hardware for mining
so miners are profitable
when their cost of resources to mine one
block
is less than the price of the reward
they receive so definitely
they have to have the investment less
than the reward what they own
so as of today in blockchain miners use
their resources to verify a transaction
they each time a block is mined new
bitcoins are created in the network so
the bitcoin total supply is limited
it is at 21 million dollars
approximately 21 million
bitcoin are in supply 17 to 18 million
bitcoins have
already been mined so only three to four
million are left as of today a reward of
12.5 bitcoin
is given to the miner on doing the
transaction
verification but the bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle
the reward given to a miner is half
every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so then after that
threshold is reached the bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 bitcoins so let's
take an example of
a lottery ticket where your chances of
winning
is difficult so we are talking about
what is bitcoin mining pool
your chances of winning the lottery is
difficult but in a community
if individuals buy multiple lottery
tickets
and pool their tickets together then
this will increase their probability and
chances of winning more so suppose you
won the lottery then based on the
contribution the reward is distributed
among
all the participants bitcoin mining pool
is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together
to mine a block now when a block is
solved the miners split the reward
equally based on the amount of
processing power they have invested so
it takes
the pool members to generate a final
hash value then it checks how much
amount of work
was contributed by each pool member and
as a result
the bitcoin reward gets distributed
proportionally
amongst the participants now let's take
a look
at a demo on how can you see what is the
bitcoin reward now
this is a actual block of the bitcoin
network
as you can see this is a block and this
is the block reward 12.5 bitcoin so this
was a block
which was mined this is the block number
and these are the set of transactions
which were part of this block now once
this block was
mined by the miner all these
transactions then be
done these are the transfers of bitcoin
from one account to the other
this is the nonce which was generated by
the miner or the
mining pool in order to mine the block
and these are the other attributes and
if you take a look
at this url this is an example of a
mining pool
it's a demo account where the
participants
have shared their mining resources and
they are mining it in a pool and see
this is the reward
for which they are mining this is the
unconfirmed reward this is the confirmed
reward this is what they have already
validated and this is what they have
earned so far
so these are the hash these are the
block numbers which they have
mine ethereum and its concepts
ethereum simply put while bitcoin
is defined as digital money ethereum
is a decentralized platform that runs
the smart contracts
exactly the way they are programmed
without any downtime
fraud and third-party interference and
also has its own cryptocurrency
called ether ethereum aims to enable
innovations
in three key areas currency assurance
through ether
which serves as an innate currency for
the ethereum blockchain
decentralized autonomous organization
smart contracts features of ethereum
the first feature of ethereum is that it
is secure
because it is almost impossible to
tamper with the transactions in the
block or to add
any fraudulent blocks in the network the
second feature of ethereum
is its community following ethereum has
attracted a lot of attention from people
all over the world the third feature of
ethereum is its corporate friendly
structure
the platform is being leveraged by a
number of corporates to test
and build various applications
the fourth feature that we will take a
look at is the possibility of creating
new assets on
ethereum blockchain that can be used as
currency
a representation of an asset a virtual
share
a proof of membership or anything at all
the next feature is the ability of
ethereum to process the transactions
fast while bitcoin requires a block time
of 10 minutes
in ethereum it's only a few seconds the
last feature that we will discuss
is the fact that ethereum is uncensored
ethereum's open source network allows
complete transparency
to view every transaction all right
that's all about the features of
ethereum let me tell you about an
important concept
in ethereum called gas
gas in ethereum gas
is the fundamental block of ethereum
ecosystem
that is paid for every operation
performed on the ethereum blockchain
it is the crypto fuel for ethereum it
can be considered a transaction fee
which has to be paid when one party
sends ethers to another party
even when a person deploys a smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain
a transaction fee needs to be paid for
that as well
this payment has to be made regardless
of whether the transaction succeeds or
fails
gas price is expressed in ether and the
miner decides
whether to refuse the transaction
process or not
based on the expected gas price one can
see their transaction fee
in eth or usd when searching for the
transaction
on etherscan.io
when somebody refers to gas they are
either talking about gas price
or gas limit the total cost of a
transaction
is the product of gas limit and gas
price
the gas limit is defined as a limit
since
it's the maximum amount of units of gas
one is willing to spend
on a single transaction this avoids
situations where there is an error
somewhere in the contract
and you end up spending a very high
amount of gas
however the units of gas required for a
transaction
are defined by the amount of code
executed on the blockchain
lowering the gas limit below the amount
required will not help much
if enough gas to cover the computational
resources
of the network is not supplied with the
transaction
the transaction will fail due to an out
of gas
error so gas is a commodity which is
essentially a cost
of using the system like bitcoins
ethereum also has its currency which is
called ether
ether it is an incentive
that the client of the platform pays to
execute requested operations
it ensures that the developers write
error-free codes
because unnecessary codes will increase
the cost
ethereum is a blockchain-based platform
and ether is the cryptocurrency that
fuels
the platform it is commonly denoted as
eth
let's have a look at the differences
between bitcoin
and ether bitcoin
versus ether the first difference is in
the hashtag algorithm
used by these cryptocurrencies while
bitcoin uses
sha-256 to encrypt blocks of blockchain
ethereum uses eth to encrypt
blocks technically both are one-way
cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
bitcoin and ether
as we have discussed earlier bitcoin is
only used for financial transactions
like
purchase and sale of goods and services
however ethereum being a touring
complete platform
also supports smart contracts and
decentralized
applications the third difference is
in the price of the two cryptocurrencies
currently
the price of btc is approximately 3 500
u.s dollars while that of eth is
approximately
100 u.s dollars the market cap of
btc is almost six times greater
than that of btc even though eth
has a higher circulating supply
the fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two
cryptocurrencies
btc is a currency created to compete
against the gold and flat currencies
by acting as an alternative however
eth is created as a token to facilitate
smart contract deployment and operations
lastly the transaction speed of btc
is much slower than eth while btc's
transaction speed is measured in minutes
eth
is just a few seconds like bitcoins
ethers are also stored in cryptocurrency
wallets
let's understand what our wallets in
ethereum
ethereum virtual machine ethereum
wallets a wallet is the place to
securely store ethers and other
cryptocurrencies
basically a wallet stores the means of
accessing your currency
using the private key now that i have
told you about the ethereum and its
currency
it will only be fair that i explain evm
now evm
ethereum virtual machine abbreviated as
evm is an engine which executes
translation code smart contracts
are compiled into bytecode which an evm
can read and execute
the ethereum virtual machine can be
regarded as a quasi
touring complete machine it possesses
its own programming language
known as the evm bytecode once the code
is written in higher level programming
languages
the code can be compiled to an evm byte
code
the ethereum virtual machine uses a set
of instructions
called opcodes to execute specific tasks
thus if a user triggers a transaction of
five
eth using his desktop wallet the wallet
sends
the message to the evm which connects
with the wallet address
on the ethereum network to process the
transaction
and send it to the receiver smart
contracts are written
in ethereum specific programming
languages
let's learn more about these languages
ethereum languages every contract
written for ethereum is compiled into
the evm bytecode
and deployed to ethereum blockchain for
execution
ethereum uses the following languages
the first language
is solidity solidity is an
object-oriented
high-level language used for
implementation
of smart contracts on the ethereum
blockchain
solidity was influenced by python
c plus plus and javascript it is
designed to target the evm
the second language is a low-level lisp
like
language abbreviated as triple l
it is one of the original ethereum smart
contract
programming languages and is similar to
assembly
it is meant to be a very simple and
minimalistic language
essentially serving as a tiny rapper
over coding
in evm directly the third language
is viper which is a contract oriented
programming language
influenced by python the fourth language
is serpent which is an assembly language
that compiles to evm code
that is extended with various high-level
features
the next language is mutant
mutant is similar to c like language and
supports a dynamic
full higher level language it compiles
to native ethereum assembler however
mutant is now deprecated the last
language is julia it is an intermediate
language that can compile to various
different backends
like evm 1.0 evm 1.5
and ewasm let me now tell you about the
accounts
handled by ethereum types
of ethereum accounts
externally owned accounts eoa
is an account controlled by a private
key that has
the ability to send ethers and messages
from it
following are some of the properties of
an externally owned account
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no associated code
smart contract smart contract
is a code running on top of the
blockchain
containing a set of rules for the nodes
to agree upon
so that they can interact with each
other as an account
it has the following properties firstly
it has an ether balance secondly
it has an associated code thirdly
a code execution is triggered by
transactions or messages
received from other contracts and
fourthly
when executed it performs operations of
arbitrary complexity
some of the advantages of smart
contracts are as follows
first smart contract is the simplest way
of implementing decentralization second
it provides a high degree of security
third it eliminates the need for a third
party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement
fifth it turns legal obligations into an
automated processes
and lastly it lowers the transaction
cost
characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self-verifying and
self-executing
they operate autonomously to execute the
terms of the contract
and verify the transactions without the
need of a third-party intervention
the elimination of third parties reduces
the cost of
operations and further makes the
contracts tamper resistant
process of smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works
first an optional contract between the
parties
is written as a code into the blockchain
the individuals
involved are anonymous but the contact
is made through a public ledger
then a trigger event like an expiration
date or a strike price has hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms
next regulators can use the blockchain
to understand the activities in the
market
while maintaining the privacy of an
individual's position
let me show you the implementation of
smart contract
in a simple use case
smart contract example
here we have an example showing the
purchase and sale of a house
thus once a buyer is matched with a
seller
all assets are sent into the contract
the contract then distributes the assets
based on certain predetermined
conditions
agreed between both parties and coded
into the smart contract
thus the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes
undisputed due to the transparency of
blockchain
eoa versus smart contract in this slide
we will understand the difference
between
an eoa and a smart contract based on
four critical properties
nonce in an externally owned account
nonce represents the number of
transactions sent
from the account's address however in a
contract account
the nonce is the number of contracts
created by the account
the next property is balance this number
shows
the amount of whey owned by the address
whether the eoa
or contract account each ether is
divided into
one e plus 18 wei the next property is
code hash it is the hash of the ethereum
virtual machine code of an account
this is the code that gets executed if
this address
receives a message call it is immutable
and thus
it cannot be changed once the
construction is done
for externally owned accounts the code
hash field
is the hash of the empty string for
contract accounts
this is the code that gets hashed and is
stored
as the code hash the last property is
storage root
it is a 256 bit hash of the root node of
a merkle tree
that encodes the storage contents of the
account
encoded into the tree as a mapping
from the key cat 256 bit hash
of the 256 bit integer keys
to the rlp encoded 256 bit
integer values this tree encodes the
hash of the storage contents of this
account
and is empty by default
that was all about the ethereum concepts
and accounts
let's understand the process of mining
now
ethereum mining
ethereum mining ethereum makes use of
proof-of-work mechanism to ensure
security
the algorithm used in ethereum is called
ethash
each time an ethereum transaction is
made a miner
is responsible for ensuring the
authenticity of information
and updating the blockchain with the
transaction
let's consider an example where bob
wants to send
one each to alice now we will take a
look at the step-by-step process
that is followed in order to confirm
this transaction
through mining first bob attempts to
send alice 1 eth
once bob's transaction is initiated it
is combined with
other transactions that have occurred in
the last block
the miners will then validate the block
with a new set of instructions
once validated the miner creates a new
block
and is rewarded for it thus
alice receives one each after the
transaction
is validated ethereum
mining the term transaction is used in
ethereum
to refer to the signed data package that
contains a message
to be sent from an eoa to another
account
on the blockchain ethereum blocks
contain two things a transaction list
and a recent state of the ledger that
comprises
these transactions in the example shown
on the screen
we can see a transaction where one
wallet sends 20 eth to another wallet
the diagram
shows the previous state and the next
state for the transaction
state storage the states are assembled
into a state tree
that is linked to the account and the
block the ethereum includes state routes
that store the root hash of the hash
tree which represents
the system state when the block was
created
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process
to see how ethereum stores transactions
first a hash is generated for each
transaction
then pairs are selected and a hash is
generated for each pair
this way the last remaining hash becomes
the root
the block header as seen in the image on
the screen
contains the previous block hash and
three merkle trees
these trees are to maintain the state
to maintain the transactions and to
maintain
the receipts also each block
always refers to its previous blocks
hash
ethereum ecosystem
types of ethereum tools the ethereum
ecosystem
consists of eight major tools they are
geth ganache parity
metamask missed wallet
swarm ipfs
whisper now let's move forward and take
a look at each of these
in detail geth
geth is a multipurpose command line tool
that runs an ethereum node
implemented in go it is the official
golang
implementation of the ethereum protocol
and is commonly used to interact with
the ethereum network
though there are several ways to
download gif the fastest one is to get
it from the ethereum.org
website next we have ganache
cli ganache cli
ganache cli is a customizable and fast
emulator for blockchain which permits
making calls to blockchain without the
need
for running an actual ethereum node
following are some of the properties of
ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost
thirdly accounts can be recycled reset
and instantiated with a fixed number of
ether
without the need for faucets or mining
fourthly gas price and mining speed can
be modified
fifthly a convenient gui gives you an
overview of your test chain events
parity parity is the fastest
lightest and most secure ethereum client
that provides the core infrastructure
essentials
for quick and reliable services parity
is written
in rust language it offers better
reliability
code clarity and performance it is an
ethereum client
that is integrated directly into your
web browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of
basic ether and token wallet it also
serves
as an ethereum gui browser it provides
access to a diverse range of ethereum
features
including d-apps metamask
metamask turns google chrome into a
browser
that allows the users to send and
receive transactions
and also fetch data from the blockchain
it is a browser-based wallet which can
be added as a plug-in to your chrome
browser
it permits you to run ethereum d-apps
directly from your browser
without the need for running a full
ethereum node
metamask accounts practically
it is unrealistic for everyone in the
world to run
a node to interact with the ethereum
blockchain
to overcome this metamask hosts a number
of nodes
so you don't have to a user simply needs
to install
metamask and can automatically get
connected to the nodes
thus you can use the ethereum blockchain
seamlessly let's talk mist
which is another important tool of the
blockchain ecosystem
mist wallet mist wallet is
the end user interface for ethereum that
is developed for browsing
and using d-apps mist is an official
ethereum wallet
it was developed and distributed by the
team which is responsible for the
management of ethereum
ecosystem it is usually used by
developers who want to create
deploy and use smart contracts
it is a full node wallet which means
you'll have to download the entire
ethereum blockchain onto your computer
some of the applications of missed
wallet is as follows
first sending and receiving transactions
second storing ether third
creating multi-signature wallets and
fourth
deploying smart contracts
swarm swarm is a platform which
supports distributed storage and
provides content distribution services
it acts as a native base layer service
of the ethereum
web 3 stack it provides sufficient
decentralization
and redundant storage of ethereum
records to distribute blockchain
data as well as d-app codes
it leverages the underlying ethereum
infrastructure
through the use of contracts and ethers
to encourage cooperation among nodes
the files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nodes of the network
an accounting protocol is used by peers
to keep track of these chunks delivered
and received and resulting micropayments
associated with it ipfs
ipfs is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to ethereum
but can be integrated with it ipfs
stores data by use of a distributed hash
table or dht once we know the hash
we request the peer network who has a
copy of the content
located at the corresponding hash and
then we download the content from the
node
who has the desired data which we need
the data transfer between the nodes in
the network
uses a mechanism which is similar to the
one used
in bittorrent it also provides
a versioned file system capable of
storing
files and tracking versions over time
thus it defines how files move across a
network
making it a distributed file system by
combining
all of these properties ipfs
is enabling a new permanent web and
augmenting the way we use
existing internet protocols like http
whisper whisper is an identity based
communication protocol
for d apps to interact with each other
d apps that need to publish small
amounts of
information to each other and have the
publication
last some substantial amount of time
prefer using whisper
for instance a d app running a currency
exchange
may use whisper to record an offer to
buy a currency
at a pre-agreed price on the exchange
platform
some of the drawbacks of whisper are as
follows
it has low level api which is only
exposed to d apps and never to users
second it has low bandwidth and is not
designed for large
data transfers third it has
uncertain latency and lastly
it has no reliable methods for tracing
packets
ethereum frameworks we'll look at two
types
of ethereum frameworks web3.js
web3.js is a set of libraries which
permit one to interact with a remote or
local ethereum node
it can be done with the use of ipc or an
http connection
the key connection between ethereum
network and dap
that allows you to compile deploy and
interact with smart contracts is called
web3.js
it gives us a way to build a website or
client
that can talk to the ethereum blockchain
let's take an example
of traditional development when you
develop a website
it talks to apis using json or
jquery to make ajax calls a website
talks to blockchain
using web3 using json.rpc
which is similar to making a remote
procedure call
ethereum comprises of a large number of
nodes which talk to each other we use
jsonrpc to make a request to a
particular node
which is like an api call thus
if we want to talk to a smart contract
or read an account
we do it through web3 ethe.js
it is a highly optimized lightweight js
utility for ethereum based on web.js
in this all the unnecessary characters
are removed
from the source code and the code is
reduced to 160 kilobytes
ethereum development environment the
three commonly used
ethereum development environments
include
remix ide truffle and
embark let's understand these
environments
in a little more detail remix ide
remix ide is a browser-based compiler
and ide that enables users
to debug transactions and build ethereum
contracts
with solidity language you can simply
log on to the web-based
editor write the code and compile the
same to create the byte code in order to
test your code
the next slide shows how remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle truffle is a development
environment testing framework and asset
pipeline for blockchains
using the ethereum virtual machine or
evm
it helps users in developing smart
contracts
publish the contracts and test them
then we have embark embark
embark is an environment that allows you
to easily develop
and deploy decentralized applications
it performs the following functions
first automatic deployment of contracts
second keeping track of deployed
contracts
third managing the complex systems
of interdependent contracts fourth
performing test driven deployment with
contracts using javascript
fifth managing different chains like
testnet
private net and livenet and lastly
redeploy the contracts if any changes
are done
let's talk about ethereum networks
ethereum network
the basis for decentralized consensus is
the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes
which maintain and secure the blockchain
a node is defined as a device or a
program
that can communicate with the ethereum
blockchain network
they are also referred to as clients
they provide wallet functionality and
allow users to perform transactions
on the blockchain thus a node serves as
a machine
running as an ethereum client it is used
to store the data
and transfer money it is formed by
combining one or more nodes
and each node contains a copy of the
blockchain
type subnetwork there are three main
types of networks
the testnet the main net and the private
network
ethereum d-apps and daos
d-app decentralized application
is an application that is used on
networks with trustless protocols to
avoid a single point of failure
they run on a peer-to-peer computer
network all the activity which takes
place
on an ethereum decentralized application
is cryptographically secured on the
blockchain
the apps are open source which means
that everyone can verify the contents of
the software
some properties of d-apps are as follows
it uses ethereum as a development
platform
it uses cryptographically encoded blocks
it is not governed by a central server
and
there is no master copy of d-app
let's talk about the advantages of
d-apps now
advantages of d-app ethereum d-apps have
the following advantages
improved stability due to a distributed
network
higher reliability automatic
credentials assigned through smart
contracts
no downtime no third party intervention
and high security example of d-apps
some of the known examples of d-apps
include
we fund storage kyc
chain and 4g capital these companies
have developed
different applications using blockchain
next we have the daos dao
daos or organizations designed to hold
assets and use the voting system to
distribute them
they exist entirely on blockchain and
are governed by the consensus protocols
they show the potential of blockchain to
revolutionize
human social institutions called daos
it is an organization run by rules
agreed through a consensus
process among its members and written in
a set of contracts
run via a blockchain it is an open
source
software capable of modification by its
members
process of a dao now let's take an
example
and see how this works let's consider
that a country is holding
elections and wants to prevent fraud in
the voting system
a dao is created to keep transparency in
the voting
this is ensured by embedding predefined
conditions
in the code people eligible to vote
are assigned voting tokens and the
voting starts
every vote is processed on the ethereum
blockchain
and it ensures transparency by allowing
everything to run
in a decentralized way in this video we
will explore
ethereum mining and we'll go through
some of the fascinating concepts
and components revolving around it first
we will have an introduction to ethereum
then we will understand what is ethereum
mining
then we will explore why should we mine
ethereum
we will look into the types of ethereum
mining
and then we will understand how the
interior mining process works
then we should explore how exactly to
mine ethereum
then we will discuss will the proof of
stake transaction kill
proof of work and then finally
we will find out is mining ethereum
profitable
so without doing much ado let's get
started with the video
let's bring you up to speed on ethereum
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy decentralized
applications and make sure all the
transactions are cryptographically
secured
in the network ether is the
cryptocurrency of ethereum
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts
and make standard peer-to-peer payments
ether basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network
it tracks and facilitates all the
transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple words ethereum mining is a
process of creating
and adding a block of transaction to the
blockchain network of ethereum
it uses the proof-of-work consensus
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network
needs to get approved by the miners
miners is a community of people using a
hashing script etas
to solve computationally hard puzzles
for successfully mining the blocks
are transactions in the ethereum
blockchain network
which helps secure the network from
attacks like hacking or manipulation of
identity
now let's understand why we need to mine
ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money
at the demanding contract of sectoring
the network enter a relatively complex
but profitable business also miners
receive a certain amount
as a reward for mining each block of the
ethereum blockchain network
including the transaction fees paid by
the users
thus italian mining benefits each and
everyone participating in ethereum
blockchain network
so what are the types of ethereum mining
ethereum mining can be performed in
three ways
ethereum solar mining ethereum coal
mining and ethereum cloud mining
in ethereum solar mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mind that item block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies
you have to be very good at your work
also solar mining is only profitable
when you have plenty of resources with
you
like 100 plus graphics cards
and in solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of area needed
italian coal mining is the easiest and
fastest way to get started with itaria
mining
in this you work along with other people
together in a single pool
and if someone from the pool gets the
hash code correctly
they share the reward among everyone in
the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool
like pool size minimum payout and
pool fee pool size determines the number
of blocks
you find in the ethereum network and it
shares rewards
as the number of miners increases the
chances to get rewards
also increase minimum payout is the
minimum amount of ethereum you need to
mine before it gets credited to your
wallet
and 40 is the amount you need to pay to
continue using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum you're mining
ethereum cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you you pay some amount of money as
peace to them
for investing their time and resources
and in return
they provide you with the reward they
gained by the mining ethereum
this this technique of mining ethereum
has some pros and cons to you
pros you're not responsible for any
equipment damage
you don't have to require all the
necessary equipment and look for ample
space to store it
you can sit back observe market and
enjoy the reward for your investment
interior mining
cons in the italian price drop then
there is no
way you are getting your money back the
money you invested or the fees
paid to the miner is lost and you can't
ask the other person to change the
equipment according to your concern
ethereum cloud mining is considered a
safer way for mining service providers
to guarantee a profit for the resource
they
have purchased
now let's understand how the ethereum
mining process works
ethereum mining follows a specific set
of steps to function
step 1 a user requests a transaction
with the help of the private key
of his digital wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pending transactions
that needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 the miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction
and perform a complex mathematical
puzzle on the transaction data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified
and it stores a copy of it in india the
process of proof of work begins
for the respective block
step six when the notes of the ethereum
network verify
at the checksum of the state of the
miner's block matches
the checksum of the updated state of the
email
after execution of all transactions
step 7 only after that the block is
added to the italian blockchain network
step 8 on successfully mining the block
it rewards the miner
with some amount of ether in their
wallet the block reward of ethereum
is 3 ether
step 9 the requested transaction is
approved
and credited for the respective wallet
or wallet
each transaction is mined only once but
every participant of the ethereum
network
verifies it this makes me curious about
how to mine ethereum
tools you will need to be an efficient
miner for ethereum
on your personal computer are an
ethereal wallet to store
all your currency on gpu drivers or
graphics card
with a minimum of 3gb ram a mining
software
suitable according to your hardware like
gpu
and a compatible operating system
windows 7 or 10
with 64 bit
before getting started with mining
iteration you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your ether
pressure model t and ledger nano are the
most reliable and secure wallets in the
market of cryptocurrency
installing gpu drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet you
need to update
all the hardware that is drives in your
system
you can use two types of graphics cards
they are amd graphics card
and nvidia graphics card
claymore is considered the best software
for mining ethereum
on gp drivers now
we need to follow a few set of steps to
get started with mining
step one download the latest version of
claymore
dual miner for the operating system the
latest version
is claymore 11.0
step 2 click on the latest version of
windows and download the zip file
step 3. extract the files of claymore
11.0 to a folder on the desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5. right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6 edit the start.txt file
and add these lines
step 7 choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better search results
than these according to your region
step 8 type in your full address instead
of mining pool address
9 save your start.txt file within new
updates
remember while saving select type as all
files
and step 10 once you save click on the
clay.that file
to begin mining ethereum
now let's explore will the proof of
state transition field trooper work
the newly introduced concept of ethereum
2.0
will roadmaps plans to upgrade to proof
of stake
consensus algorithm in which it will
provide all existing miners
authoritarian network
with a limited time to earn a return for
the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021
or the starting of 2022. it was supposed
to be launched by october 2020
but the history of delays regarding this
update is worth talking about
nobody truly knows when ethereum 2.0
will be completed
and introduced to the crypto mining
world
now when we know all about ethereum
mining
this makes me wonder if ethereum mining
is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity
in that particular area as a rule
anything below
0.12 per kilowatt consumes in an hour is
considered
profitable you can mine ether and turn
it into a
vital source of income by analyzing
these figures
like hash rate of ethereum block reward
number of blocks per day and the coin
price of ethereum
you can also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors
or you can use this formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise
and become more stable in the coming few
years so it is an excellent opportunity
to invest in and save in ethereum in
this video
we will explore ethereum 2.0 and will go
through some of the fascinating concepts
and components revolving around it
so what is the ethereum network ethereum
is defined as a blockchain based
computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy decentralized application
ether is the cryptocurrency for ethereum
used to build decentralized application
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
it tracks and facilitates all the
transactions
and make sure they are cryptographically
secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades
that will make the ethereum network more
secure scalable
and sustainable multiple teams
from across the ethereum ecosystem have
come together to work on these upgrades
in ethereum 2.0
then what led to the region of ethereum
2.0
with growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network has gotten more blocked
by transactions
currently it is capable of handling 15
to 45 transactions per second
which is comparatively impressive but it
is not enough to handle all of italian's
users
worldwide also the high demand is
affecting the driving up of transaction
fees
nodes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently
its nodes are experiencing too much
volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed
that making its nodes bigger wouldn't be
practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable
to handle all of the activities on the
ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.0
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of stake
and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations
suffer from performance issues because
they rely on a processing power
intensive process luna's proof of work
to record and validate their
transactions
the problem with proof-of-work design is
that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof of stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput
gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency
and ability to scale in the current
version of ethereum blockchain
all data that is added to the chain
undergoes verification by
all participating nodes that means that
the speed of its fluids
participant limits the processing speed
of the entire network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources
by breaking data verification tasks
among its set
of nodes and each of them will be
responsible for validating and verifying
just the data allotted to them
this will increase the network's overall
capacity and make it much
faster and efficient than its outdated
version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
while ethereum 2.0 has been in research
and development
since 2014. it has actually been making
some progress
the beacon chain went live in december
2020 introducing the staging concept
but still there is no official claim for
the completion of this transition
the next phase is mainnet merging the
beacon chain
into the current ethereum network mining
ethereum tokens
will officially end in this phase and
staking will become the primary way
to create new tokens in the ethereum
network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the shard genes to give the
ethereum blockchain network
more capacity and efficiency to handle
all of the demand
and increase transactions per second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing
the ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated
and on their way to completing the whole
transition so
what is the future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0
could be a total game changer it will
create a modified network
that could potentially process one lag
transactions per second
and a much more sustainable network
without the energy intensive mining
process
and it will introduce smart contracts
worldwide increasing the ethereum's
network utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
alex buterin once
said that the issuance of new token
should be highly reduced under ethereum
2.0
which could increase its demand given
all these factors ethereum 2.0 seems to
hold a bright future for ethereum
blockchain network
in the previous videos we covered what
bitcoin and ethereum are
let's proceed further and have a look at
how they both differ from each other
did you know there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies worldwide
and among them bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies
in the world by market cap also
recently ethereum as well as bitcoin
reached its all-time peak
in worldwide trading according to
decrypt.go
everyday new companies like meetu and
paypal are coming forward to invest
in bitcoin and ethereum on march 7 2021
metoo confirmed that it had purchased 40
million in bitcoin and ethereum
on the other hand people is about to
launch a scheme
with the public in purchase and sell
cryptocurrencies
initially featuring bitcoin and ethereum
via paypal digital wallet
but have you all ever wondered how they
compare based on their similarities and
differences in various aspects
well before moving any further let's
have a quick look at how bitcoin and
ethereum originated
and made a benchmark in the economic
system worldwide
bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
satoshi nakamoto
to resolve cyber attacks double spending
and eliminate the middleman between the
transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent
and decentralized peer-to-peer
transaction on the other hand
ethereum came into the picture years
after bitcoin
it was first introduced in the late 2013
by vitalik buterin
after that it was very quickly and
widely adopted
because it offered a platform to build
and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of
any third party ethereum serves as a
computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized application
now let's move ahead and see the
difference between them
which make them compete with each other
in this economy
this video will cover individual aspects
for comparing ethereum and bitcoin's
performance
in that particular field first we will
look into the introduction of ethereum
and bitcoin
then the algorithm they follow the
programming language
mining process of ethereum and bitcoin
monetary policy transaction and
availability of these two
cryptocurrencies
by time bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency
however ethereum with different
functionalities is giving a quite tough
competition to bitcoin
but before moving ahead let's have an
introduction to ethereum and bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an
application for its users without any
centralized interference
for bitcoin it is an alternative to fiat
money or physical currency
the main function of ethereum is to
provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using dapps or decentralized application
on the other side bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money
and value stored in its blockchain
network now let's get started and move
towards the first comparison
which is algorithm ethereum uses the
etas cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network
on the other hand bitcoin uses the
she-256 hashing algorithm for mining
blocks in the bitcoin network
etas algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function
proof of work is a small piece of data
that is difficult to generate
but easy to validate and satisfy certain
network requirements
sag 256 algorithm helps bitcoin
users to protect all their sensitive
data like private keys
moving on the programming language of
ethereum
and bitcoin ethereum uses solidity
solidity is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
but in terms of programming language
bitcoin keeps it simple
bitcoin uses c plus as its programming
language
it is a stack based programming language
used to give bitcoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies
now let's take a look at the mining
process of both mining is a process in
which transaction made are validated and
added
to blockchain public ledger and blocks
and the people mining these blocks
are called miners ethereum miners mine
the unvalidated transaction
using the proof of work method but it
aims to switch
to proof of stake because it will make
its network
more immune to centralization energy
efficient
and stronger support for its shared
chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the
proof-of-work method to mine unvalidated
transactions
these method is enough to function in
bitcoin network worldwide
now let's proceed towards the monetary
policy of both cryptocurrencies
but let's first understand what monetary
policy is
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting
announcing and implementing the plan of
actions
taken by the competent monetary
authority to control the money supply
and achieve goals that promote
sustainable economic growth
so italian's policy is defined by the
reward
paid out by its protocol ethereum's
monetary policies
are best described as minimum issuance
to secure the network
therefore there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
but bitcoin's monetary policy comprises
two parts
halving and block frequency halving
event is when the reward
of mining bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate and the
block reward is the number of bitcoins
you get
if you successfully mine a blockchain
block the current block reward for
ethereum is two ether per block
and for bitcoin the block reward is 12.5
bitcoins
per block also every 14 seconds
a block of ethereum is generated and one
block of
bitcoin take 10 minutes to generate
monetary policies are considered to be
fixed and non-inflationary
due to this over time mining blocks will
become more difficult
next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it
on the other side bitcoin's transaction
speed is 5 transactions per second
and it can take up to 60 minutes or more
to confirm
either the currency of ethereum acts as
the fuel for ethereum networks
and bitcoin is only used as the value
for real-world transaction
to compete with already present
electronic cash like credit cards and
google pay it rem and bitcoin require
higher productivity to attain widespread
adoption
not talking about the availability of
both cryptocurrencies
ethereum is not limited but it can
occasionally reduce due to large
network upgrades however bitcoin is
limited to 21 million coins
and as of today 18 million bitcoin is
already used
but in the end both bitcoin and ethereum
being the top
crypto currencies share a few
similarities
like both are decentralized and can be
used to have
a peer-to-peer transaction proof of work
also both have a large network of
independent nodes
now let's have a demo now let's have a
look at the media outlet website
coindesk where we will see all stats
related to bitcoin and ethereum in
detail
coindesk is a site specialized in
digital currencies
it is used to explore the news and price
data related to cryptocurrencies
and also explains how cryptocurrencies
contribute to the evolution of financial
system
worldwide now see this graph this graph
shows the change in bitcoin price
in 24 hours duration this graph shows
the gradual change in the price of
bitcoin it started from 64
hundred thirty nine point two nine
dollars on april 14
at 12 p.m and right now by april 15
at 6 00 am it is at 63
189 the rate of change is minus 0.46
percent which shows the change in the
price of bitcoin
per hour let's have a look at this graph
of ethereum two the value of ethereum
started at two thousand three 388.13
on april 14 at 12 p.m and the current
status
on april 15 is positive with a value of
2442.37
an increasing rate of 4.67 percent
down below we have a metrics table that
shows the change between the starting
and ending value of ethereum the total
supply of a cryptocurrency in 24 hours
the total number of transaction that
occurred and the average transaction fee
for all these transactions now this
graph
shows the current status of
cryptocurrency in usd dollars
we can also see its value according to
any centralized currency
like euro or inr this graph shows the
concentrating change in the value of
cryptocurrencies
every moment we can also access the data
of trading
from an hour to its lifetime recently
we all have been hearing about a
cryptocurrency famously known as
dogecoin
but what exactly makes it so different
from others that almost every person
is talking about it so let me tell you
that dogecoin is an altcoin
and an almost sarcastic mean coin that
serves as a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency
well that's not enough so let's dive
down
and understand the concept of dogecoin
more precisely but before starting
let's have a look at why is it in the
news since the beginning of the year
2021
dogecoin has surged more than 950
percent
from less than half a penny to more than
5 cents per dogecoin then
elon musk ceo of teslin corporation
took his interest in it and tweeted too
much concentration is the only real
issue
for cryptocurrency making the owner of
the deutsche coin wallet a subject of
attention
later on other celebs like snoop dogg
also started taking an interest in
dogecoin
and started tweeting and promoting it on
social platforms which made dogecoin
climb to a peak of 8.2 u.s cents and
market capitalization of 10 billion
dollars
in this video we will come across the
following topics
first we will see the origin of dogecoin
and then we will understand
what is dogecoin how does it exactly
works
and then we will see what led to the
growth of dogecoin
what are the areas of uses of dogecoin
then we will figure out what is the
current value of dogecoin today
and lastly how can we buy it let's start
with the origin of dogecoin
was invented by two software engineers
ibm engineer billy marcus
and adobe engineer jackson palmer did
you know that they never even met before
combining the two most significant
phenomena of the year 2013
bitcoin and deutsche well now let's move
ahead and see what is dogecoin
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency
that provides its user a completely
unknown
decentralized and secure environment
free from any third-party interference
to make their transaction
dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin
inspired by shiba inu's popular meme aka
doge moving ahead let's have a look at
how it works
to understand the workflow let's take
the example of two friends
mark and susan mark owes some money to
susan
and now he needs to return it so he
thinks of an idea
and decides to send her dogecoin instead
of giving her physical money
they both open their digital wallet
account
to pay her he needs two essential pieces
of information
first his private key and second her
public key to get access to
susan's private key he needs to scan a
qr code
from his smartphone then the application
alerts all the dogecoin miners around
the world to proceed further with the
process
the dogecoin miners validate where the
mark has enough dogecoin
to make the payment or not and after the
validation process
they approve the transaction request
dogecoin miners
race with each other to collect all the
data of the pending transaction
known as the nonce the miners then apply
a mathematical function to produce the
correct hash number for the particular
nonce of the pending transaction
the miner who successfully produces the
correct hash number is rewarded with 25
dogecoin in his account
after that mark and susan gets a
confirmation message
that they request for the transaction
has been approved
and within 10 minutes the requested
amount of dogecoin is credited into the
wallet of susan
thus the transaction is completed so
what led to the growth of dogecoin
dogecoin officially came live in 2013
and became
an instant hit within the community of
people who just wanted to play around
the cryptocurrencies freely
as i said earlier dogecoin was intended
to be a joke for content creators but
they were very well received it
uses of internet forums like reddit and
twitter
adopted dogecoin and started tipping
their content creators
this usage of dogecoin made it surpass
the trading value of the other
cryptocurrencies
specifically bitcoin in 2014.
it also started doing charity work to
introduce and promote themselves in the
real world
for example once they raise a fund of 55
000
dollars for a nascar driver josh weiss
and in return he printed the logo and 98
dogecoin over this race car
eventually it almost became the mascot
for what crypto should be
let's have a look at who uses dogecoin
today many companies and firms like
restaurants processors web hosting
products retailer ebook sellers and
travel services uses dogecoin for
transaction
these are a few examples of companies in
every sector
that uses dogecoin grosser's hello pets
gamerheats.com for web hosting
gamer for products retailer meltdown
and noddex ebook seller canal
and travel services like bello leo dot
it
this makes me curious about the current
value of dogecoin
let's have a look at that too according
to the market cap today the current
value of dogecoin is 0.05
usd with a trading volume of 16 billion
dollars
the circulating supply of this
cryptocurrency is
129 billion dogecoin and the max supply
of dogecoin
is not available how can we buy dogecoin
so to buy dogecoin we will have to
follow a few steps
step 1 open a digital wallet buy you
coin is considered a perfect application
for trading cryptocurrencies
step 2 register your account step 3
complete your profile kyc by providing
your identity and address proof
like aadhaar step 4 add your bank
account details
step five secure your account by
creating a convenient trading pin
that is only accessible by you
and step six there you go
now you can start trading that is all
about dogecoin
currently we have heard a lot of buzz
about the cryptocurrency dogecoin
and the shenanigans of its community did
you know that on 20th
april 2020 dogecoin searched its value
to
one dollar making this day named after
itself
as day the supporters of dogecoin
were trying to amplify the value of it
to make it one dollar
but how is it done in reality how can we
affect
the value and availability of
cryptocurrency
well all this is done by a process
called my name
and this is what affected torch coin
resulting in the rise of its value
mining coins of the deutsche coin
network is called dogecoin mining
now let's move ahead and see what's in
this video for you
first we will have an introduction to
what is dogecoin
then we will figure out the net worth of
dogecoin today
we will understand what dogecoin mining
is
then we will have a comparison of mining
process of dogepoint
with a few other cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin
then we will dive into how to mine
deutsche coin in this segment
first we will see types of dogecoin
mining like pool
and solo then we will see what exactly
you require
to start dogecoin mining what hardware
and software you need
for those coin mining and then we will
understand a new concept of dogecoin
mining
which is dogecoin cloud mining
and in the end we will analyze but the
dogecoin mining is profitable
or not so let's get started and have a
quick look
at what is dogecoin dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer open source cryptocurrency
that works on blockchain technology also
it provides its users a completely
unknown decentralized
and secure environment free from any
third-party interference to make their
transactions
dosh uses skiptography to secure all its
transactions
this makes me curious to know what is
the net worth and availability of
dogecoin today
according to market cap today the
current value of dogecoin
is 0.266247 usd dollars
the circulating supply of this
cryptocurrency is 127 billion dogecoin
so that brings us to what is dodecoin
mining
dogecoin mining is a process of
validating
the data blocks of transactions by
solving a complex mathematical problem
and adding them to the dogecoin network
each confirmation of transactions adds a
new block to the dogecoin network
miners perform this process those and
miners are a community of people
who perform complex mathematical
solutions on the transactions
for mining dogecoin that makes me wonder
what the difference
between dogecoin mining and other
cryptocurrencies mining process
let's have a comparison between those
coin mining and the bitcoin mining
process
we will be comparing these crypto mining
based on these factors
first algorithm it is a set of rules
that every cryptocurrency
follows for mining new coins in the
algorithm
dogecoin mining uses script bitcoin
mining uses
she-256 script is considered a lot
quicker and cheaper than the
algorithm making mining easier for
miners of the dogecoin network
second is difficulty this represents the
complexities
and challenges faced by miners to mine
each block
of the blockchain of any cryptocurrency
in difficulty dogecoin is two million
seven hundred ninety eight
thousand two hundred fifty two bitcoin
is
three trillion five hundred eleven
billion sixty million
five hundred fifty two thousand eight
hundred ninety nine
thus it proves that dodge coin is easier
to mine among other cryptocurrencies
third is block time it is the time taken
by a new block of transactions to be
checked
confirmed and added to the blockchain
block time of dogecoin
is one minute for bitcoin it is 10
minutes
and at 4th and 5th we have reward per
block
and per block usd it is the amount
in usd to the miner for each block added
to the network
block reward for dogecoin is 10 000
dogecoins
per block which in usd is 27.36 dodge
coins
for bitcoin it is 12.5 bitcoin per block
and in usd it is 86
391.63 bitcoins
moving on finally we have reached the
most crucial point of this video
now we will have a look at how to mine
dogecoin
dogecoin can be mined in two ways the
first one
dogecoin pool mining and the second is
solo mining
a dogecoin pool is a group of people
who share their computing power to mine
dogecoin transaction data
and get rewarded by equal share after
confirming the transaction
solo mining is when only one person does
all the work of mining and confirming
transactions
the reward is awarded only to that
person after confirming the transaction
let's have a thorough discussion of the
difference between deutsche
pool mining and solo my name
in dogecoin pool mining you have to mine
as a part of it
and pay fees in dogecoin solo mining you
don't need to pay any fees
and your mine all by yourself
also in pole mining you will only get a
part of the reward earned by the poor
one but in solo mining the total reward
earned will be received by you only
as in pole mining many people work
together so the mine blocks more often
and on the other side solo mining could
take a lot of time before
one mine their first block
in pool mining it takes less time to
confirm a transaction as you work as a
part of the pool community
on the other hand in solo mining it can
take much longer to confirm a
transaction
as you do all the work and there is a
lot of competition
so this was all about dogecoin pool
mining and solo mining
let's proceed further and see what we
need
to start mining dogecoin
but before we start mining we will have
to make sure that we have these things
with us
a pc with any operating system like
windows
linux ubuntu etc a good internet
connection
and a digital wallet to store the dodge
coins you might
which hardware and software can be used
for dogecoin mining
you will need your pc cpu which should
be powerful enough to mine dogecoin
a gpu or graphics card can also be used
for mining dogecoin for example sapphire
pulse radeon
rx 580 asus rx vega 64
and many more stripped asic miner
is programmed to mine strip based
cryptocurrencies like dogecoin
like bitmain antminer l3
bw l21 strip miner etc
if you are new to dogecoin mining then
using your pc cpu will be the right
choice and cpu miner is the most
appropriate software
if you are thinking of mining using gpu
or graphics card
you can have a wide range of software
some of the best software is buddha
miner which works perfectly
with nvidia products cgminer which works
with
most gpu hardware and easy miner is
considered
suitable for beginners script asic
miners are considered to be very
powerful
hardware and multi-miner is excellent
with this hardware
moving ahead let's understand what does
coin cloud mining is
doing cloud mining is a mechanism to
mine dogecoin using rented data centers
without installing any hardware and
related softwares
it allows people to take an interest and
participate in deutsche point mining at
a very low cost making dogecoin mining
accessible for a broader range of people
worldwide
since the dodge coin mining process uses
the cloud it reduces equipment
maintenance
or direct energy cost
this whole concept of dogecoin mining
brings me in front of one question
is dotecoin mining profitable
doj coin mining profitability can be
analyzed based on power consumption
hash rate and cost the doj coin mining
calculator
is used to make it simple in this
calculator
the default value for the latest
dogecoin mining hash rate
and latest dogecoin difficulty target is
pre-loaded for better results
dogecoin mining's reward is 44 lakh 44
412.25 dollars per year
that is 14 million doge per year
the block time for dogecoin is one
minute which means the supply of
dogecoin will never go
down after deducting mining power costs
and mining fees the final daily dogecoin
mining profit is
22.53 dollars torch coin to usd with a
profit margin
of positive 81.72 percent
also i think dogecoin mining is fun so
that is all about dogecoin mining we
covered
what dogecoin is its value today and
understood dogecoin mining and its
concepts in the previous two videos
now let's proceed further and look at
how to create a dodgeball wallet
and how to use it let's get started what
is torch point
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency
that works on a blockchain technology
also
it provides its users a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment
free from any third-party interference
to make their transactions
torch coin uses cryptography to secure
all its transactions
now let's proceed further and have a
look at the process
of how to buy dogecoin you can buy
dogecoin by following
these steps step one create a dotecoin
wallet
step two locate your specific dogecoin
address
which is a long area of characters that
starts from capital d
followed by any other capital character
or any number
and step three find the source that
sells dogecoin
and vola buy dogecoins so that brings us
to what is dogecoin wallet
a dogecoin wallet is something where you
can stop store
receive or send dogecoins technically it
is very similar to a real live wallet
dogecoin wallet consists of its public
and private key
connecting it to the distributed ledger
over the dogecoin network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address
for your bank account number for
dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made
by maintaining the anonymity of the user
the private key of your wallet is used
to approve transactions
in the ledger your wallet's public key
is used to receive dodge coins from
other users on the other hand
your wallet's private key is only used
to send torch points
to other users in the network so what
are the types of dogecoin wallet
dogecoin wallet is of two types digital
dogecoin wallet
and physical dodgebind wallet digital
dogecoin wallet
is accessible through the web and you
can also download it
according to your handset or operating
system
on the other hand physical dogecoin
wallets are pretty expensive
and less accessible so moving on let's
see how to create a dogecoin wallet
to create a doj coin wallet for yourself
you will have to go through the
following steps
step 1 choose the correct wallet
dogecoin core wallet and multi-touch
wallet have been created
and are maintained by the developers
team of dogecoin
here we will be using the dojo and core
wallet as reference
step 2 download and install the dojo
wallet
in your handset you can also use the
official website of this wallet
for your windows and step 3. open the
dojo and wallet application
and verify your dogecoin wallet address
and that is it
it is this easy to create and have your
dogecoin wallet
now when you have your douchecoin wallet
in your hand
let's see how you can use it on the very
bottom of the home page of your wallet
there are two options request coins
where you can request torch coins from
other users
in the dojo network and send coins
where you can send dodge points to other
users in the dogecoin network
to receive coins first click on the
request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third have the below generated
barcode scanned by the user
you wish to request the amount
now to send coins first type the
dogecoin wallet address to whom you want
to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send and there you go
now you can use your dogecoin wallet
whenever and wherever you want
this makes me wonder why is dogecoin so
popular
despite being in tough competition with
other strong cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin
dogecoin has never missed an opportunity
to be in the limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
community
other than that social platforms like
reddit and twitter
also promoted dogecoin to a great extent
due to its fun factor
and the whole joke story behind it
celebrities
like snoop dogg kevin jonas elon musk
also started taking an interest in
dogepoint and posting pictures
and comments on their social media
handles which increase the craze of
dogecoin
all around the world so this was all
about dogecoin wallet
now let's have a look at the top 5
deutsche point wallets of 2021
these are the top five dogecoin wallets
of 2021
ledger nano x trees model t kepke
binance and kraken kraken
is primarily a cryptocurrency exchange
platform
but can perfectly act as a dogecoin
wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dodge coins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform
it charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it
and it accepts a pretty decent amount of
fiat money
what comes to your mind first when you
hear the word torch coin
i'm pretty sure either it's a meme or
a musk well whatever we think of this
cryptocurrency
we can't deny the fact that dogecoin
started as a joke
not turned into the crypto star of the
future
everyone one or the other way knows
about dogecoin
but do you know what makes it so unique
and popular in this video i will take
you through some amazing top 10 facts
about dogecoin
so let's get started number one
dogecoin has several safety levels
security levels are partially based on
the number of nodes of cryptocurrency
dogecoin has 1090 nodes which makes it
irresistible to hacking plus sometimes
the traffic increases in the dogecoin
network
making it more vulnerable to its
security
number two huge and interactive
community of followers
among all of the cryptocurrencies those
coin today has the biggest community of
followers
they genuinely believe that dogecoin
will rule the future
and this unity proved to be an advantage
for dogecoin
for instance once china banned all the
payment companies dealing with bitcoin
which led to the increase of dojo and
reddit users up to 19 000
in just two weeks thus the price of
dogecoin escalated
to 300 percent those coins followed
provide full support to dogecoin and
acting unity to try
every bit to make it more popular and
grow
once they raised a fund of 55 000
dollars
for a nascar driver john weiss who in
return covered his entire car
with dogecoin and reddit alien images
such a beautiful family
number three dogecoin is the easiest to
buy
the platform for cryptocurrency exchange
provides the
most convenient ways to buy dogecoin
all you need is to create a digital
wallet which can be done on any
cryptocurrency exchange platform's
official website
and choose a reliable exchanger like
kraken or coinbase
and you will also need some bitcoins to
exchange it with doge
that's it it is this simple to trade
dogecoin
now you can get rolling with bangdorje
coin
number four doj coin wallet inspired by
lucky coin
dogecoin was based on lucky coin as both
of them used the script language
to make dogecoin more ridiculous palmer
and marcus added a weird feature to the
dogecoin wallet
stating that its miner could receive
either 0
or potentially thousands of free coins
to produce new blocks inspired by one of
the quirky features of lucky coin
after a while they change the block
reward to a fixed number of 10 000 to
make it more feasible
well i think dogecoin needs to be a
little different from these
cryptocurrencies
as it holds a different history of
original growth
to maintain the faith of its community
it needs to upgrade itself a bit
number five largest circulating supply
of the coin
dogecoin in the crypto market holds the
position of the largest circulating
supply of coins
since both the founders of dogecoin
wanted it to be a ridiculous joe
they thought of generating as many
dogecoin unit as possible
therefore they ended up making a
circulating supply of 127 million
dogecoin
which is relatedly higher than the
volume of other cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin or ethereum
till today almost 113 billion dogecoins
are already mine every day
10 000 new dogecoins are released in
block rewards
every minute roughly 14.4 million new
dogecoins entering into the circulation
every day therefore 5.2 billion
dogecoins
per year dogecoin mining process
is one of the fastest at least
98.98 dogecoin can be mined
every day dogecoin uses script
encryption
which cannot be harvested using asics
making it easier and faster to mine
other than cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
also the block rate is one block per
minute this provides an
excellent opportunity for miners to mine
more blocks
and earn as many block rewards as
possible
and miner can make make at least 10 000
dogecoins
as a block reward
number seven market capitalization over
435 million dollar
when dogecoin was first introduced to
the crypto world it was supposed to be
taken as a joke
but the people very well received it
this led
its more value than 435 million
by 2017 i don't know about
others but this value of money is a lot
imagine if you had invested 1000 on
dogecoin in january 2017 and then sold
it all
after a month do you know how much money
you would have earned
almost 22 thousand dollars today the
market cap worth of dogecoin
is 70 billion dollars making it the
fourth
most valued coin
number eight huge fan following in the
entertainment world
dogecoin seems to have gained a lot of
popularity among celebrities like
snoop dogg kevin jonas
gene simmons and elon musk recently
kevin jonas the eldest jonas brother
posted saying all i was saying
doge showing his interest in dogecoin
gene simmons from the classic
rock band kiss also made a massive
revelation
that he owns six figures worth of
dogecoin
well some have been posting funny
pictures or comments
to promote this crypto over social media
and some have been trying to change the
perception
of people for dogecoin number nine
widely represented on social media
dogecoin has been widely represented on
social media
since its origin platforms like reddit
and twitter adopted dogecoin in its
initial days
and started promoting it by tipping
dogecoin to their content creators
which turned out to be a massive success
for dogecoin
dutch con began to catch the attention
of every user on these platforms
i feel twitter has been a slam book for
torch coin as every day one or the other
person tweets about dogecoin there
later other platforms like tick tock
also started developing their interest
in dogecoin
in summer 2020 tick tock introduced a
dogecoin challenge to encourage
people to invest in dogecoin number 10
elon musk the flag bearer of dogecoin
when deutsche is mentioned how can we
not talk about tesla ceo elon musk
but the question is what makes him love
dogecoin
so much recently one of his followers
tweeted and asked him
why do you love dote so much he reacted
that he loves dogs
and loves memes he has been so active
with dogecoin by constantly tweeting
about it
his first tweet was torched to the moon
which grabbed the attention of both the
followers of elon
and followers of dogecoin this led to
the overnight increase in the price and
popularity of dogecoin
later he posted a still from lion king
movie which with his face in place of
rafiki
holding simba with the face of dogecoin
stating that he will always have
dogecoins back
his most recent tweet was on wednesday
may 5 2021
the dogecoin father snl may 8 which is a
reference to both his constant tweets on
dogecoin
as well as his appearance on saturday
night live on may 8 2020.
in the previous few videos we learned
about what dogecoin is
and we also had a comparison between
ethereum and bitcoin
in which we talked about their features
and concepts behind the mechanism
but in this video we will compare and
contrast dogecoin
bitcoin and ethereum based on a few
related concepts
around these cryptocurrencies it will
help us understand the functioning
of these top cryptocurrencies and will
also let us figure out the individuality
of each one of them
dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin inspired by shiba inu's
popular meme
aka doj but it was very well received by
everyone in the crypto world
and today it is the fourth top
cryptocurrency
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency
that provides its users with a
completely unknown
decentralized and secure environment to
make their transactions
bitcoin led the first revolution of
digital money in 2013.
bitcoin enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
bitcoin is designed to be an alternative
to national currencies and intends only
to be a medium of exchange
and value storage it comprises of
features like a public ledger
immutability and high transparency
making it a great platform
ethereum came into the picture years
after bitcoin ethereum
offered a platform to build and run
applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its
developers to build and deploy their
decentralized applications
using smart contracts through its
currency ether
or eth the primary function of ether is
to help developers
build smart contracts using dapps or
decentralized application
now let's move on to comparison between
dogecoin
bitcoin and ethereum we will be
comparing them
based on few major parameters like
algorithm programming language
mining process monetary policies
transactions today's value
and availability so let's move
ahead and start with the very first
comparison the algorithm
dogecoin uses strict cryptography for
mining the blocks of the dogecoin
network
in comparison bitcoin uses the sha-256
hashing algorithm
for mining its blocks in the blockchain
network
ethereum on the other hand uses the e
dash algorithm
for mining its transactions
script language is a password-based key
derivation function
that is mainly used to avoid customized
hardware attacks by raising the resource
demands of the algorithm
she 256 algorithm helps bitcoin users
protect
all their sensitive data like private
keys or transaction details
and help maintain the anonymity of the
user for a much secure performance of
transactions
e-algorithm is mainly used during the
proof-of-work function
proof-of-work is a small piece of data
that is difficult to generate
but easy to validate and satisfy
specific network requirements
moving on the following comparison
programming language
dogecoin is considered to be an all coin
for bitcoin
vote dodge coin and bitcoin use the same
programming language
c plus it is a stack based programming
language
used to give bitcoin and dogecoin
software instructions on how to make
transactions
on the other side ethereum uses solidity
which is a high level programming
language
used by ethereum for implementing smart
contracts
now that we have covered programming
language and algorithm of this
cryptocurrency
let's get to the following very
important parameter which is
mining process but
before getting started with the
comparison first let's understand what
mining
is mining is a process in which
transactions
are validated and added to the
blockchain public ledger in blocks
and the people mining these blocks are
called miners
in terms of the mining process also
dogecoin and bitcoin use the same method
to verify
and validate the pending transaction in
the networks
and that is proof of work although
ethereum miners also
mine the unvalidated transactions using
the proof of work
method it aims to switch to proof of
stake
because it will make its network more
immune to centralization
energy efficient and more vital support
for shared chains
now we have come to the following person
which is monetary policy
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing
and implementing the plan of actions
taken by the competent monetary
authority to control the money supply
and achieve
goals that promote sustainable economic
growth
dogecoin's policy is defined by its
block rewards paid to its miners
whereas bitcoin policy is defined by two
processes
having and block reward having event is
when
reward of mining bitcoin is cut in half
and it also cuts the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain
block an
ethereum's policy is defined as minimum
issuance to secure the network
that is there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
dogecoin's block reward is 10 000 for
mining one block
bitcoin's block reward is 12.5 for
mining each block
and which is set to get reduced to 6.25
by 2024
and ethereum's block reward is 2 ether
per block
dogecoin takes one minute to generate
one block
bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate one
block
and ethereum generates one block every
14 seconds
well monetary policies are considered to
be fixed and non-inflationary
due to this over time mining blocks will
become more complex
now moving on to the following
comparison which is
transactions dogecoin is the fastest
and can complete 70 transaction in one
second
and takes just two to three minutes to
confirm a transaction
bitcoin can complete up to five
transaction in one second
and takes 10 minutes or more than that
to confirm one transaction
an ethereum can complete 30 transactions
per second and it takes just a few
minutes to confirm it
dogecoin is majorly used for tipping
content creators on social platforms
like reddit and twitter
bitcoin is only used as a superior
alternative
for fiat money and is used primarily for
real-world transactions
on the other hand ether the currency of
ethereum
acts as the fuel for ethereum networks
now that we have covered all about
transaction process of these
cryptocurrency
let's have a look at the value of
dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum
in today's date
the value of dogecoin on today's date is
zero point
two nine nine two dollars
bitcoin being the highest is thirty four
thousand eight hundred fifty seven point
five eight
an ethereum holds a value of two
thousand 2356.58
now we have reached the last comparison
of dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum
which is availability
the circulating supply of dogecoin is
127
billion bitcoin very low as compared to
dogecoin
is just 21 million in circulation
ethereum on the other hand is said to be
unlimited
but till today the circulation supply of
ethereum
is 115.6 million
till today 113 billion dogecoin has
already been mined
for bitcoin 18 million bitcoins are
already mined
and for ethereum roughly 36 million
ethereum
has already been mined
in this draft you can see the red box on
the right side of the graph
shows the maximum supply of dogecoin on
the extreme left
you can see first the options that you
can use according to your requirements
like if you want to know about dogecoin
you can go for the first option that is
www.dogecoin.com
which will lead you to the official
website of dogecoin
if you want to chat with the executives
of coin market regarding dogecoin then
you can go for the fourth option
which is chat before that
is an address for binance address
through which you can keep a track of
dogecoin's value on that platform
and you can also change it according to
your choice by clicking on more
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of dogecoin
which is thirty eight billion thirty
eight hundred
forty nine million four hundred sixty
nine thousand ninety eight
it is the total value of dogecoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
which is 38 700
795 9006.
it is the capitalization when max supply
of dogecoin was in circulation
and on the right side just before total
supply you can see the volume of
dogecoin
one billion seven hundred seventy nine
million
four hundred seventeen thousand six
hundred forty seven
it is the value of dogecoin traded in 24
hours
next is bitcoin similar to dogecoin
you can see the red box on the right
side of the graph shows the maximum
supply of dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options
that you can use according to your
requirement
like if you want to know more about
bitcoin you can go for the first option
that is www
bitcoin
which will lead you to the official
website of bitcoin
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of bitcoin
which is 651 billion
thirteen million ten thousand seven
hundred fifty three
it is the total value of bitcoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted
market capitalization that is 732
billion
387 million two hundred sixty two
thousand
six hundred ninety and on the right side
just before the total supply you can see
the volume of bitcoin
that is thirty billion two hundred forty
nine million
nine hundred thirty nine thousand eight
hundred sixty five
ethereum is no different from dogecoin
and bitcoin in this
also you can see the total supply of
ethereum
also you can visit the official website
of www.ethereum.org to explore more
about ethereum
you can have a look at the market cap
value of ethereum which is 273 billion
755 million five hundred eighty six
thousand five hundred thirty four
the fully diluted market capitalization
is
273 billion five hundred seventy six
million
nine hundred eighty seven thousand forty
nine
the volume of ethereum traded in 24
hours is twenty four billion
one hundred one million seven hundred
seventy nine thousand
three hundred forty six but in the end
all these top cryptocurrencies dogecoin
bitcoin and ethereum
share a few similarities like they all
are decentralized
all three cryptocurrencies are free from
any third-party interference or any
centralized authority
and can be used to have secure and
independent peer-to-peer transaction
maintaining the anonymity of the user
and proof of work that is all their
transactions are verified
and validated before processing after
complete verification
further transaction process takes place
also all of them have a large network of
independent
nodes meet susan an aspiring painter
she wishes to conduct an online painting
exhibition for all her digital artworks
however as the exhibition is online she
is worried that her paintings won't be
secure
as anyone could easily forge or
replicate them
her friend mark came to her rescue with
an idea of nft
he suggested that susan could buy nfts
for all her paintings as nfts are
trustworthy
easily transferable and will also
maintain her ownership rights on her
artworks
susan had no idea what nfts were so mark
stepped ahead and explained it to her
nfts turn your digital assets into one
of a kind
by creating a unique digital signature
which defines the ownership of your
assets
and that can be bought and sold for real
money cryptocurrency
or any other asset like a non-fungible
token
aka nft non-fungible tokens means that
they are not interchangeable
and each of them represents unique
assets owned by a specific person
on the other hand fungible tokens are
interchangeable and can be divided into
smaller units to form the same value
for example a 100 bill is fungible as
you can exchange it with five twenty
dollar bills or two fifty dollar bills
but the painting of the last supper is
non-fungible as it cannot be generated
in bulk
even if it is copied it will not be
authentic
each nft contains distinguishable
information like who owns the digital
asset
and who sold it making them distinct and
easily verifiable
as it is impossible to forge such a
certificate it will secure her
painting's originality
after learning what nft is susan was
curious to know
how exactly nft works nft basically
creates a blockchain based digital
certificate for your digital
collectibles
including games music art and many more
this certificate
gives your artwork a unique identity the
underlying technology
and the programming language used by
nfts are the same as other
cryptocurrencies
such as blockchain and the programming
language ethash
or script nft majorly exists on ethereum
blockchain
a distributed public ledger that records
all the transactions
however nft is quite different from
these cryptocurrencies
bitcoin and ethereum are fungible tokens
which means if you trade bitcoin or
ethereum for one another
you will have the same value or item in
return basically money
on the other hand nft is a unique token
therefore
if you try to trade it you may end up
with something completely different in
your hands
crypto punks is a remarkable example of
nft
it enables you to buy sell and store 10
000 collectibles with the proof of
ownership being stored on the ethereum
blockchain
after exploring hal nft's work susan was
convinced
and bought nfts for all her paintings
due to this
her artworks were secured from any kind
of forgery and also gave her artworks a
particular value
this contributed to increased sales too
as everyone was easily able to buy the
artwork without any fear
all in all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others
like jack dorsey the ceo and co-founder
of twitter with his very first and
famous tweet
just setting up my twitter and vignesh
sanderson
famously known as medicovan who bought
69.3 million dollars worth of nft art on
people
owing to its increasing popularity
people are now willing to pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars for
nfts nft has enhanced media exposure
and special perks for aspiring artists
like susan on social media
this popularity of nft creates new
opportunities for new art platforms
motivating people to buy art from
internet platforms and promoting
copyright or originality of digital
assets
so here's a question for you what makes
any item non-fungible
a exchangeability b unique digital
signature
c tradeability d distributed public
ledger
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
many experts in the crypto industry say
that around 40 percent of new crypto
users will use nfts as their entry point
as a result of its growing popularity
nft could represent a more significant
part of the digital economy
in the future in this video we will
explore about
shiva in a coin and we'll go through
some of really exciting concepts
and components revolving around it so
how did the shiba inu coin originate
the shiva inu coin was created in august
2020
by an anonymous person calling
themselves ryoshi
an indian it was intended as an
altcoin of dogecoin which itself was
created as an altcoin of bitcoin
and this meme coin has been named after
the japanese dog breed
shiva inu it feels like the shiba inu
coin was built into existence
and is now insanely popular among major
crypto exchanges through the power of
its following crowd
memes and a very cute dog now we know
how it originated
so let's have a look at what is shiba in
a coin
shiva inucoin is a decentralized
community building cryptocurrency
or we can say an experiment developed
within the shiva inno ecosystem
and built on top of the ethereum
blockchain network
like many other coins it is a meme coin
launched as a rival
of dogecoin or doge killer both dogecoin
and sheepcoin were made in a humorous
manner
but sheepcoin has already taken over
some dogecoin markets
attracting a lot of attention and rising
as a popular choice among
investors especially after such market
crash of cryptos like bitcoin
and ethereum but
what is the difference between sheba and
coin and dogecoin
although both shiva and coin and
dogecoin are meme coins
and share the same tree of origin both
of them differ a lot
from each other at the same time and the
very first difference between them is
the sheep coin is a token
and dogecoin is a currency
let's have a look at more of those major
differences like this
first is development shiba inu coins
or sheep coins are built on and powered
by the ethereum network while dogecoin
has been developed using the same
technology as bitcoin
then is use cases sheepcoin is still
working upon price
more due to its high popularity than
utility
but on the other hand dogecoin has
already established
itself to some extent as a medium of
online payments
there is value according to my coin
market cap
the current value of sheep coin is 0.000
7378 and that of dogecoin is
0.261711
and at last availability the
availability of
sheep coin till today is 394 million and
for dogecoin
it is 130 billion
now this definitely raises a question in
my mind why
is she buying a coin so popular
shimano coin is majorly popular because
of two reasons
tesla founder elon musk has tweeted
recently expressing that he would like
to own a shiba pub
that hyped the crypto market and its
prices rose
by 300 on the other hand
its prices fell by around 40 percent
after the founder of ethereum blockchain
network
with alec buterin donated 50 trillion
shiba new coins to
indian government for corporate relief
fund of an indian crypto entrepreneur
sandeep naival
so now that we know about shiba in a
coin and its concepts
let's have a look at what is the future
of shiba you know coins
though sheba coin is only known as a
meme coin
its increasing popularity and people's
interest and participating in it
is pointing towards a different but
bright future
according to investing cube.com the
shiba
coin is predicted to rise again
although there isn't much movement among
this token
and its value active buyers could help
its value rise
the value could rise to 0.00
1040 in a more active buyers market
although it may not appear to be a
significant amount
due to its popularity in future it can
have
a significant influence over large
investors of the crypto market
in this video we will explore some of
the interesting
and important aspects of solana crypto
first we will understand what is solana
then we will look into what is a soul
token
or sol token
then we will explore when and how did it
originated
after which we will look into some of
the features of solana
then we will explore what type of
consensus method
does solana use
after which we will understand how
solana works
then we will explore the current price
and volume of solana in today's date
after that we will look into the future
of solana
holds for itself and at last
we will look into real-life uses of
salaana
so without doing much ado let's start
the video
let's explore what is solana
is a cryptocurrency that is used to pay
for transactions
or a decentralized computing network
solana attempts to increase blockchain
scalability
by combining proof of stake and proof of
history consensus
as a result solana promises to be
capable of processing 50 000
transactions
per second while maintaining
decentralization
now the question arises what is the sl
token
or soul token sonata's ecosystem uses
the sl token
as its native currency as a result the
token can be transferred between nodes
in the solana cluster
in exchange for running on-chain
programs or certifying their results
it can also be used to make
micropayments known as lamports
now when we are talking so much about
solana crypto
let's also dive down and explore how and
when
exactly it came into existence
anatoly yakovenko established the solana
platform in 2017
before launching solana yakovenko
worked at balcom after working as a
software engineer at dropbox
he has a wide spectrum of knowledge with
compression methods
he developed a new method of dealing
with typical throughput difficulties
in the bitcoin and ethereum blockchain
with the help of eric williams and
solana cto
greg fitzgerald
they intended to develop a trustless
distributed protocol
with increased scalability the team now
has experience
from leading companies around the world
including apple
google microsoft intel twitter
dropbox and others
now that we know what solana is and all
about its background
let me ask you a question recently
solana joined hands with two
foundations to raise a fund of five
million dollars to encourage the next
wave of creators
and fans onto crypto networks so comment
down your answers in the comment section
below
to know the correct answer to this
question watch this video till the end
moving on let's talk about its features
which makes it
unique and popular scalable solana uses
proof of history
and a number of other groundbreaking
features to allow the network
to scale at the rate of moore's law
low cost for applications with billions
of users solana is designed
to keep fees low so you will never have
to worry about
rising fees as your user base grows
composable the single global state of
solana
guarantees project composability
multiple shards and layer 2 systems
should never be dealt with
so we have heard a lot of references to
proof of history
but what exactly is it that we will
discuss within the type of consensus
method solana uses
the salina network which has 200
physically different nodes
can handle a throughput of more than 50
000 dps
when using gpus is one of the most
performant permissionless blockchain
unlike bitcoin which employs the proof
of work algorithm
as the system decentralized clock solana
uses the proof of history technique
you can use proof of history to
construct historical records
that verify an event occurred at a given
point in time
this algorithm is a verifiable delay
function with a high frequency
this function requires a specific number
of sequential steps
to evaluate each transaction or even
that is examined
will be assigned a unique hash an
account that can be verified publicly
and effectively
the count serves as a cryptographic
timestamp allowing us to determine
when each transaction or event occurred
this provides
increased throughput and efficiency
within the solana network
now that we know about its structure and
mechanism
let's explore how solana works
now we know solana has built a
one-of-a-kind method for determining the
time
of a transaction known as proof of
history
let's see the step-by-step procedure of
how it works
step 1 input the details of transactions
performed
in the network to its leader
step 2 leader will now efficiently
sequence
and organize the messages so that they
can be processed
by another nodes step 3
the leader then executes the
transactions based on the ram's current
state
step 4 the completed state's
transactions and signature will then be
published by the leader
to the verifiers or replication nodes
step 5 if the state receives
confirmation
the verifiers will perform the same
transactions on their copies
of the state and publish their
signatures
and at last step 6 the consensus process
will then use
the published confirmations as votes now
that we know everything about solana
let's have a look at the price and
volume of solana according to market
capitalization
the solana network can process more than
50 000 transactions in one second
and the current price of it is 30 with a
circulating volume
of 270 million sql coins
which is quite impressive considering
its time span in
market capitalization as well as
compared to other cryptocurrencies
let's see what future the solana holds
for itself
svelana although being a new project has
delivered on its promises of speed
and scalability it's token price has
also
done well attack attracting investors
attention
nonetheless the network acceptance and
usage
are still in the early stages
we won't know whether solana speed make
a significant difference in the bitcoin
realm
until we witness substantial traffic and
more use cases
having a fast network is beneficial but
the advantages
will only occur as more people utilize
it
and more use cases emerge real-life uses
of solana
serum radium bone pedal orca
oxygen and phantom wallet are some of
the recent projects
that solana is working with well this is
all about solana crypto
recently you all must have noticed that
the crypto market
has caused quite a buzz in social media
and other online forums
and perhaps even in your dinner time
conversations
but what is all this commotion about
this is about
the recent downfall of cryptocurrencies
in the crypto market
in this video we will let you through
some very important aspects of this
phenomenon of cryptocurrency first of
all we will understand
what cryptocurrency and crypto market
are after that
we will understand how the market works
then we will look into the reasons for
the market crash of cryptocurrency
and how it has affected people at all
levels
then we will figure out the factors that
can help the market to grow again
and at last we will look into the future
of cryptocurrency
and trip to market so let's start with
the very first aspect
that is what cryptocurrency and crypto
market are
a cryptocurrency is a kind of virtual or
digital currency
that works on blockchain technology a
public ledger
enforced by a distributed network of
computers
it works as a medium of exchange online
to buy
goods and services and make payments
like for example
bitcoin ethereum dogecoin these are some
of the popular cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency is decentralized and free
from any third-party interference
which means it is not issued or
controlled by any government
or central authority the crypto in
cryptocurrency stands for cryptography
which uses encryption and decryption to
secure the data
crypto market is where you can trade
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency trading
is an act of speculating the price
movement of cryptocurrency
without taking ownership of the
underlying coins
through a trading account or by buying
and selling the underlying coins through
an exchange
you can buy cryptocurrency if you think
it will rise in value or sell them
if you think it will fall now let's
understand how it works
the price of crypto currency is quoted
in traditional currencies
such as the us dollar and you never take
ownership of the cryptocurrency itself
one can buy and sell at cryptocurrency
through their trading account or via
exchange
which helps them speculate on whether
the chosen cryptocurrency will rise
or fall in value both buy
and sell are leveraged products which
means you only need to put up a small
amount as a deposit
known as margin to gain total exposure
to the underlying market
your profit or loss is majorly
calculated based on the total size of
your position
so leverage can affect your profits as
well as your losses if the market moves
against you
so that makes me question what the
reasons behind the market crash of
cryptocurrency
are on 19th may 2021 the crypto market
saw a massive drop
in prices or crypto currencies including
bitcoin
ethereum and bnp crashing up to 30
within a span of just 24 hours this came
in the backdrop of the chinese
regulators
announcing a ban of cryptocurrency
china has banned payment companies and
financial institutions
from providing any services such as
registration
trading clearing and settlement related
to cryptocurrency transactions
this announcement made by china broke
the markets back
and then the panic increased because
tesla announced
that they would not favor bitcoin on
environmental concerns anymore
therefore they will not accept any
payment made by bitcoin
and also there are rumors of irs
investigation into the largest crypto
exchange platform
binance which also has weakened
investors resolution to invest more in
crypto market
now we know the reasons behind the
crypto market crash
so let's take a look at how it has
affected people at all levels
the crypto market means different things
to different people
it is an object of speculation that
consumes
almost all the media coverage about the
space to many people
for them the day crypto market crashed
was a
black day as they faced a tremendous
loss of the leverage
invested in cryptocurrencies even the
bloomberg galaxy crypto
index plunged 19.2 in its
worst slide in more than a year
and to others the crypto market is more
than a speculative
instrument for them this incident proved
to be a huge opportunity
as they got a chance to uncover problems
of the system of the crypto market
like high fees to trade at the most
crucial moments
and find solution to these problems by
adding more capacity
and efficiency to the system so now we
have covered everything about the market
crash of cryptocurrency
let's dive into the factors that can
help the market to grow again
despite their dramatic downturns these
cryptocurrencies have
consistently recovered from their
downtime people in the crypto market
systems
have termed this decline as a short-term
correction
long-term investors like microstrategy
call this crash a buying opportunity of
these cryptocurrencies
and is investing more to stabilize them
many people believe that
what we witnessed in the last few days
was the liquidation of the leverage
long positions followed by a panic
sell-off and is considered a very normal
phenomenon
in thin markets like cryptocurrency
they believe that this situation can be
thought down
by extensive adoption of cryptocurrency
and constant participation
in the crypto market well this whole
scenario
makes me question what the future
cryptocurrency and crypto market holds
cryptocurrency is a highly speculative
and volatile
investment and it may or may not succeed
over time
therefore there is no guarantee for
these cryptocurrencies that all will
always recover from this type of market
crashes
a few experts of the crypto market say
that investors
should hold a long-term view of the
digital assets market
as they will bounce back swiftly also
small investors should be better off
staying away from the market
as this current volatility can be
overwhelming for them
and some experts suggest that holding on
to these cryptos
will be a wise option and small
investors should buy these cryptos
slowly and steadily through a systematic
plan
therefore if you're thinking about
investing in cryptocurrency
be sure you know what you're getting
into although the crypto market is
lucrative
keep in mind that there's always a
chance that sometimes cryptocurrencies
are not able to bounce back
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on cryptocurrency
full course i hope you found it
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you